guten morgen aus münster wir stehen hier
vor dem johanniter stift in münster vor
ungefähr einer halben stunde als wäre
gerade hier angekommen sind ist ein
transporter von kühne & nagel gekommen
und das war auch ein sehr großer zufall
und der hat den impfstoff gebracht ist
dann rein gegangen hat den der
einrichtungsleiterin übergeben und die
steht auch hier vor mir frau schiedel
was ist das für ein gefühl heute dass
ihre bewohner endlich geimpft werden das
ist ein gefühl das ist ein gefühl von
freude wir freuen uns auf den impfstoff
wir haben ja das ganze zeit in der
presse auch verfolgt dass der impfstoff
entwicklung voranschreitet und das ist
heute so weit ist das macht was man
zuversicht also wir freuen uns auch
heute dass es endlich starten kann für
die bewohner und auch die mitarbeiter
also insbesondere die risikogruppe jetzt
waren es ja acht monate die auch ihnen
und auch den bewohnern viel abfall amt
an
wie haben sie das durchlebt und wie
haben sie jetzt auch die bewohner
aufgeklärt was jetzt eigentlich passiert
heute ja das ist richtig wir haben eine
sehr herausfordernde zeit hinter uns
jetzt aktuell ist es so dass wir
eigentlich schon seit mehreren wochen
ist das impf thema bei uns ja nicht
alltag aber wird immer mal wieder
angesprochen und wir haben schon im
vorfeld über einen impfstoff gesprochen
über das impfen und jetzt aktuell ist es
so dass wir vor knapp einer woche oder
knapp zehn tagen die aufklärungsbogen
verteilt haben
und die einwilligungserklärung also
entsprechend die dokumente die dafür
notwendig sind
wir sind mit den bewohnern und den
angehörigen und betreuern gesetzlichen
betreuern ins gespräch gegangen
mit den ärzten zusammen hier in münster
dem impf themen die uns auch begleiten
und haben nun letztendlich mit den
entsprechend betroffen sind wir die
dokumente durchgegangen teilweise
einzelgesprächen und mit angehörigen
zusammen so dass wir letztendlich heute
sagen können wir haben eine
95-prozentige impfbereitschaft bei den
bewohnern und bei den mitarbeitern auch
von 85 prozent aber ja das war mit ein
bisschen vorlauf und mit durchaus ein
bisschen bürokratischen beziehungsweise
reaktions aufwand verbunden
aber in der summe mit allen die daran
mitgewirkt haben ist uns das in der
kürze der zeit gut geglückt ja wenn sie
uns mal eben kurz einmal mit es wird ja
dann heute im laufe des tages geimpft
wie haben sie die bewohner jetzt heute
darauf vorbereitet sind die nervös und
wie läuft das dann ab wenn das im team
dann kommt nur damit wir uns das mal so
ein bisschen vorstellen
alle die spannender weise sind die
bewohner gar nicht nervös die freuen
sich wirklich drauf es gab keinen da
irgendwie gesagt hat mit mit ängsten
besetzt gar nicht das sind wirklich die
gehen damit sehr souverän um
und ich kann wirklich noch mal betonen
dass die wirklich heute sehr gelassen
auf den tag blicken also da gibt es
überhaupt keinen da irgendwie sagt euch
hab angst ganz im gegenteil die sind
wirklich so dass es das sie sich freuen
dass es heute losgeht weil auch den sehr
klar ist dass durch die impfung wenn sie
denn dann in drei wochen und danach der
einen woche wenn der volle impfschutz
wirkt oder wirksamkeit ist dann dann
haben sie hat eine sicherheit dass ihr
mit 95 prozentiger wahrscheinlichkeit
geschützt sind und das ist allen
eigentlich sehr klar entschieden sie
jetzt sagen sie noch mal kurz für ihre
mitarbeiter war das ja auch eine sehr
herausfordernde zeit
sie haben im vorgespräch gesagt sie
haben auch natürlich die kontakte
eingeschränkt erzählen sie mal ein
bisschen wie sind auch das team so
zusammengehalten hat und auch für die
alten leute da also die acht monate
waren wie sie schon sagten sie
herausfordernd wir haben wir waren
wirklich aufgefordert sehr kreativ mit
der zeit umzugehen wir haben relativ
früh im april betreuungsangebot so um
konstruiert zu haben sind in einzel
begleitung haben wir mussten natürlich
auch angehörige weil ihr werden anfangs
auch eine besuchs sperre wenige wochen
lang und da haben wir einfach weil die
angehörigen oft auch mit bewohnern
spazieren gehen das haben wir
kompensiert über den sozialen dienst wir
sind viel draußen gewesen wir haben
kleingruppen angebote umgestrickt waren
berufsgruppen nochmal mit aufgaben
umverteilt so dass wir eigentlich
rückblickend sagen können das ist uns
gut gelungen ist soziale teilhabe auch
für die bewohner in dieser zeit bei
eingeschränkten kontaktmöglichkeiten
durchzuführen und das ist ganz gut
gelungen die mitarbeiter haben sich ja
und da mein wirklicher lob an alle die
hier arbeiten sehr verantwortungsvoll in
der in den letzten 10 monate knapp
wirklich verhalten sie haben alle sehr
bereitwillig selbst private kontakte
eingeschränkt teilweise ja auch auf
urlaub in den sommermonaten verzichtet
wir haben viel auch gesprochen über
hygienemaßnahmen auch eigeninitiativ von
den mitarbeitern aus wie verhalte ich
mich kann ich mir das noch mal angucken
wie geht das
hygiene kleine mit denen durchgesprochen
auch von deren seite aus kamen da viele
fragen
im rahmen von wie verhalte ich mich
richtig so dass sie eigentlich heute
sagen kann dass wir keinen einzigen
bewohner fall hatten die ganze zeit über
auch bei den bewohnern als auch bei den
mitarbeitern